so let's get some practice and hopefully
a little bit of intuition for adding and
subtracting two dimensional vectors so
let's say that i have vector a
and
let's say that its x component is
i don't know three and its y component
is negative one
and let's say we also have a vector b
vector b and let's say that its x
component is two and let's say its y
component is three
now let's first think about what would
a
plus b equal so what resulting vector
would this be
a plus b is equal to
what
and i encourage you to pause the video
and think about what this would be
well the convention is is if we're
taking the sum of two vectors we can
just add up their x their x components
to get our new x component and add up
their y components to get the new y
component so the x component of vector a
plus vector b is going to be 3
plus
that's going to be the x component which
we know is 5 and the y component is
going to be negative 1
negative 1
plus 3
plus 3. and so the resulting vector is
going to have an x component of 5
and a y component of negative 1 plus 3
is equal to 2.
all right that was pretty
straightforward now instead of adding
them let's think about what would happen
if we subtract them so let's think about
what a what vector a minus vector b
would be and i suspect that you might be
able to guess or at least think about
what would happen if you subtract vector
b instead of adding vector b
well as you might have guessed instead
of adding the corresponding components
we subtract it so our x component is
going to be the x component of a minus
the x component of b because it's vector
a minus vector b so our x component is
going to be 3
minus 2
and our y component
is going to be the y component of a
negative 1
minus the y component of b
so
minus 3
and so the resulting vector is going to
be
is going to be the vector 3 minus 2 the
x component is going to be 1 and then
the y component negative 1 minus 3 is
negative 4. now what i just showed you
this is a convention for adding and
subtracting 2 dimensional vectors like
vectors a and b let's think a little bit
about how we can visually depict what is
going on so let's first visually depict
adding vector a and vector b
so let me draw some axes
and so my
so this could be
there's my
y axis
y axis let's see the highest y value i
get to is
the highest y value i get two is three
and the lowest is negative four
and then so let me draw the x-axis
someplace
whoops i didn't mean to do that i did
the zoom by accident all right
so the x-axis
put it right over there
there's my x-axis
and let's see the highest x value is
five the lowest is three actually i
could just focus on the
i could just focus on the
let me just focus on the right hand side
so that's y
and then let me do
x
looking
like
that
x axis and now let's see vector a is 3
comma negative 1.
so
2 3 and negative 1. if we want to just
visualize it in standard form we could
put its initial point at the origin and
its terminal point at the point 3 comma
negative 1.
and so we could draw it like that we
could also shift it around as long as it
has the same as long as it has the same
magnitude and
direction
we can shift it around so that right
there is our vector a
now vector b 2 comma 3 we could have its
initial point at the origin and just we
could draw it like this
so the x coordinate is 2 y coordinate 1
3. so its terminal point could be there
so we could just draw it like this
or vector b
but if we're going to add vector b to
vector a like we have right over there
what we want to do is shift vector b
over so that its i guess you could say
tail starts at a's head or its initial
point starts at a's terminal point so
let's do that so if we start right over
here
we're going to go 2 in the x direction
so we're going to go two more in the x
direction and we're going to go 3 in the
y direction so 1
2 3. so we're going to end up
right over there so notice this is the
same vector vector b i've just shifted
it over has the same magnitude and same
direction as what i had drawn before as
that vector right over there i have just
shifted it down and to the right and now
when we do this so this is vector a i'm
adding vector b i put the tail i put the
initial point of vector b at the
terminal point of vector a i've shifted
it over right over there so now i can
figure out the resulting vector a plus b
the resulting vector a plus b by going
from the initial point of a to the
terminal point of b
so it's going to start here and then go
over there and notice this vector i'm
going 5 in the x direction and 2 in the
y direction this is the vector 5 comma 2
right over there that is vector a plus
vector b
now let's think about what happens when
we do a minus b well we could still have
vector a just like we drew it but now
instead of putting vector b's
tail or or initial point at the terminal
point of vector a we would want to put
negative b so negative b would just be
have the same magnitude would have been
it would be in the opposite direction
so instead of going 2 to the right and 3
up we would go
2 to the left and 3 down so just 2 to
the left and
3 down would end we would end up
right about there
and so if you subtract a minus b that's
the same thing as a plus negative b
so negative b is going to look something
like this it's going to be the exact
opposite direction
it's going to look
it's going to look like that and so
there if you start at the initial point
of a and get to the terminal point of
the negative b now
this is all hand drawn so it could be a
little bit more precise notice we get to
the point 1
comma
negative 4 1 comma negative 4. so this
vector right over here we do that in a
different color
this brown whoops that's not what i
wanted to do this brown vector right
over here
that is the vector a minus b and then
this white one actually let me do this
in another color as well this magenta
vector
right here that is a plus b so hopefully
that makes sense and if you given the
components you just if you're adding the
vectors add the corresponding components
if you're subtracting the vectors well
if you're subtracting b from a subtract
b's component corresponding components
from the corresponding components of a